for people watching this who
are artists or for you know i always
tell artists that there's really no
excuse for you to not
be on your [ __ ] in 2020 2021 because
you know the internet from from from
when you first got in we were talking
earlier
you know the days of like you needing to
meet someone and pass them your tape or
all that's just gone
like you know you're straight to
consumer now but like what are the
things that
that you would tell up-and-coming
artists um that they need to have
like together you know what i'm saying
to be taken serious
i mean you know what bothers me a lot of
upcoming
artists don't even take the time to
figure out who the players are in the
game
so you know like i hate when people come
up to me and they'd be like oh you work
me what do you do like it'd be like then
they be like oh can you take i'm like
i'm not about to explain what i do today
right like you know like
when i was coming up i knew who
everybody was at every label
so if i didn't run into them i would
know something about their story
to be compelling enough for them to want
to take my information
nowadays that's why i dm'd you even
you'd be like bruh
what is that move right right right now
i'm saying so
i mean honestly you know i think what
held me best was being a student of the
game
and realizing what people did before me
to get to where they're at
you know reading books and things like
that to kind of help put me on the path
to understanding what it takes to be
good at what i do but
you know i think just understanding that
and just worth ethic
you know the entitlement is is at an
all-time high
at an all-time high right now it's very
it's very concerning for me
you know what i'm saying because on the
artist side and on the and on the
background like on
you know like on your side yes it's bad
man like you know everybody wants to
the big salary big check but don't want
to check in